the former deputy commissioner longtime
Commissioner of the NBA and also a
basketball Hall of Famer and a general
manager of the Bulls the time who
drafted Michael Jordan Rob thorn here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you rod
doing great rich how are you I'm doing
fine I'm sure your phones blowing up in
the last five weeks huh definitely have
a lot of I'm sure you have I have some
questions for you sir if you don't mind
I appreciate you taking the time to
answer them
first things first did you learn
anything from the last dance rod you
know I did rich there were some clips
that I'd never seen before you know
knowing Michael reasonably well I
thought that he put himself out there a
little bit more than I would have
expected because you know toward the end
of his career he was pretty guarded you
know and what he said and how he was you
know warned himself to be to be looked
at and that surprised me a little bit
but I think the basic gist of it pretty
much covered him and it was very
compelling TV it sure was rod let's
let's go back to the the the draft
period for you when when you were third
on the clock did you get any calls for
the trade the pick for somebody wanted
Jordan did you get any calls for that
you know rich not when we were on the on
the clock we didn't we had had bunch of
calls prior to the draft from teams
interested in the third pick I can
assume that they were interested in
Jordan with that pick but there were
there were several teams who were
interested there were a couple of teams
that
we're more interested than others mate
you know what I think you know people
would probably call reasonable offers to
remember that particular pic remember
the names of the teams you remember any
of the names of the teams rot that you
thought know what two teams they're two
teams who were who made the better
offers Philadelphia Dallas okay what
could have been and you just said no
thank you what could have been and you
said well thank you that we we knew
about a week before the draft that we
that Jordan would be available Portland
and my conversations with Stu and then
it was the GM of the Blazers had told me
that if samberly passed his physical
they would draft him and about a week
before the draft I called him and asked
him the Bowie past and he said yes and
asked him if if they were still gonna
draft him and he said yes so we knew
week before the draft that unless you
know some crazy trade or something
happens which sometimes does around
drafts that Jordan would be available at
number three so was this a time where
people didn't lie about their intentions
for a draft right you took took his word
for it there no he was he was not kind
of lie or the kind of guy who was if he
told you you know he might tell you it's
none of your business or we have made up
our mind yet but in this case he didn't
and he was telling the truth
so prior to you receiving this
information or potentially in the event
that he might have had his lips moving
and it wasn't really true what was your
backup plan at number three if Jordan
was gone what would you have done if
Jordan were if Jordan had been gone we
would have taken Sam Perkins my fielding
you know Charles Barkley was in that
graph mm-hmm and my feeling
about Berkeley and I check out of
Berkeley a bunch of times was that it
was too small to do in the NBA what he
was doing at Auburn and you know Sam
Perkins had a nice career and was a very
good player but that would have been a
mistake well I'm assuming that you spoke
to Dean Smith about both Tar Heels what
was your conversation with Dean Smith
about Jordan prior to that draft right
well you know I had you know developed a
relationship with Coach Smith you know
you know we'd go down and watch practice
from time to time and at the end of
every year he would allow me to watch to
come in and watch his tapes where you
know you could scout not only the Tar
Heels but also the other ACC teams and
Michael's Jimmy here when he came out
you know I'm watching tape and you know
he stands out you know like a sore thumb
with his athleticism with how much
better he had gotten from the time he
entered North Carolina until his junior
year and when I was talking to coach
Smith after watching tape all day he
said to me that and he would never say
it publicly because you know that's not
the Carolina way that Jordan was the
most talented player that he had coached
and pa said he's and he's a really solid
good person on top of it but you know he
would you know he would never say oh but
he said that to you and how did that
land on how did that land with you when
you heard him say something like that
advocate of Coach Smith I thought he was
a great coach sure and I thought he I
thought he prepared his players very
well for the NBA if you look at kill a
lot of players over the course of time
and and and particularly when when coach
Smith was
there most of his players were better
pros than there were college players not
there there aren't many coaches you can
say that about you know some coaches get
everything is possible to get out of a
player when he's in college and then
when you get him in pro ball they don't
improve that much most Carolina players
under Coach Smith and I think part of it
was the way they played you know they
didn't they didn't you know put any one
player above any other player they
played a very team-oriented game and
they you know really delved into the
fundamentals of the game and and most of
their players became better pros Rod
Thorn here on the Rich Eisen show
Basketball Hall of Famer and then when
you and the Bulls parted ways you became
the executive vice president of
basketball operations in other words the
the league's chief disciplinarian just
at a time when the bad boys were hitting
and just the time when people start
hitting each other and just the time
when really things were really getting
particularly physical did you ever what
what was your conversation with Chuck
Daly like about his team lamb beer any
of these guys you ever have
conversations like lamb beer Mahorn
saying what is your malfunction well we
had a we had conversations with Leah
people duty to the the game played in
the late 80s and part of the 90s was
much much different than the game today
we instituted we instituted some changes
during the 90s that really calm the you
know the very very physical play you
were allowed to hand shift you know
cutters got chucked all the time if you
drove to the bucket you probably were
going to get knocked down is not up
ended and and the game had got you know
just got to a point where it was it was
too physical that strength and power
were negating talent and what if you
look at the NBA
most people would say the NBA has
they're as good as any other sport it's
not better and if you are allowing
extreme physicality in the game which we
which we had for a while that's not a
good thing for your game and it changed
with you know the flagrant final rules
and then you know not allowing and
checking and today it's a free-falling
game much different game that was in the
late eighties early nineties but it's a
you know the fans seemed oh yeah you
know the physicality is nothing on what
it was well I mean I'm part of the last
dance that left so many people talking
rod was about the bad boy Pistons and
the relationship between the bad boy
Pistons and the Bulls and thus obviously
Michael Jordan and Isiah Thomas and I
want to I guess revisit this issue with
you since you were on charge of
essentially selecting who played in the
first or the first major dream team in
1992 how did Isaiah Thomas not wind up
on my team I know you've been asked that
many times over the last several weeks
but I'm the first first time I get this
shot so how did he not wind up on that
team you know rich CM Newton who was the
athletic director of Kentucky at the
time was the chair of the committee okay
Russ Granick and myself because we were
NBA people and we were part of the
committee right we're asked by the
committee to talk with the players who
we had a meeting in Orlando say in early
April of 1991 were we identified five or
six players I forget exactly what it was
the five or six players that we would
you know would be essential basically to
have on the team and arrest and I'm you
know contacted those people Jordan was
one of the guys that I contacted you
know out of that out of that crew and
you know those people agreed that they
would
participated on June along the team
Isaiah obviously was one of the guys
that was looked at very closely he was a
tremendous player one of the top point
guards that we've had in the NBA there
were five or six other guys James Worthy
Reggie Miller come to mind Dominique
Wilkins Kevin Johnson
Tim Hardaway come to mind right away and
there were others that were looked at
and the committee in you know the
committee had in on an Olympic team
you've got 12 players of which 11 were
pros when you pick all-star teams you've
got 12 on each side so you got 24
players and look you know a lot of guys
get left off that you could make a great
case for and in in the case of the dream
team there were several people who got
left off prominently Isaiah who I'm sure
if he had been selected you know would
have been would have been terrific but
the committee did not select is the
reason why he was not selected that
somebody said I don't want in there he
can't be there because of not not you
know if you're alluding to a player no
it had nothing to do with any player how
about anybody anything - how about any
Commissioner to me I do know that there
were a lot of you know the the the when
the Pistons walked out didn't shake
hands with the Bulls you know at the end
of the the first year the bill Bulls one
I think was 92 maybe 91 92 somewhere in
there there you know there was there was
some angst you know among NBA people
about you know what had transpired the
Pistons you know plate of very very
physical game which upset a lot of
people so there was some acts you know
I'm not going to tell you that there
wasn't some acts but obviously chuck was
the coach of the team
and although he didn't have anything to
do with you know we're picking other
than you know making you know talking
about you know he had like thirty
players that he felt we should consider
which we did you know the committee did
but no there was no one player that two
players are three plus or three players
that I've read about who said to me or
to Russ grant for in a terminology that
they didn't want to play with any
particular player so would you say if
Isiah Thomas shook Michael Jordan's hand
at the end of that Eastern Conference
Finals right before the dream team
selection he would have made it in
Barcelona would you say that I can't say
that rich but I think it would have
helped well but I can't say that for
sure
you know we had we had eleven people on
the committee of which Jack McCloskey
was one of who was the GM of other
Pistons at the time he later resigned
from the committee when Isaiah didn't
you know wasn't selected but he was part
of that committee and so he is that the
reason why he resigned because Isaiah
was not selected yes so it sounds like
it was an interesting day and that
sounds like an interesting debate in
that room went down rod I mean you know
it was but but but it would not only was
you know a debate regarding Isaiah but
there was a debate about other players
what about Chris what about christian
Laettner over Shaq Ron what about that
one
well the we had agreed the USA
basketball had asked the NBA if they
would put one collegiate player on there
because the collegiate players had
represented the United States for so
many years and we agreed to it you know
a long time before it it was it the the
relator was in
of 1992 after the season
Laettner had been two-time Player of the
Year he had been a two-time champion
with Duke and the USA Basketball was
pushing him because he he had not only
you know have a terrific career Duke but
he had played for USA basketball in most
every time they had asked him to play
hip late Shaq was a younger player and
so Laettner you know was the guy that
got chosen there Clyde Drexler at that
same meeting who had had a obviously had
a great year with Portland and they had
played in the finals against Chicago and
he was the 12th guy selected rod last
quick one for you if you don't mind
rod thorn here on the Rich Eisen show
you must know Jerry Reinsdorf very well
and obviously Jerry Krause was the man
who succeeded you in the role in in
Chicago a lot of discussion as to whose
fingerprints were on the end of the last
dance and why the team got broken up
what Jerry Reinsdorf ever let crowds do
something on his own or was crouched
doing everything that Reinsdorf wanted
him to do best you could tell you know I
think that you know if you if you look
at the record you can't argue with the
records you know six championships
I think crowds made one of the great
trades in the history of the league when
he during that draft when he traded
olden Polynice for Scottie Pippen did
some you know and obviously did some
really good things that helped that you
know that particular group play as well
as they did so he deserved a lot of
credit I don't think he felt he got
enough credit and I think he was looking
forward to rebuilding the team and
hopefully making it into another
you know championship type team didn't
work out that way you know for the next
four or five years and then he was let
go at the end of that but I think he was
looking forward to that
rod really appreciate the time thank you
for doing it and let's let's shut down
the road really appreciate it thank you
thank you rich enjoyed it thank you
right back at you that's Rod Thorn
Basketball Hall of Famer hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here